one of the most humiliating things that
you can say about someone is they choked
and boy do I know that feeling
growing up I was an avid athlete my main
sport was soccer and I was a goalkeeper
which is both the best and the worst
position on the field you see when
you're a goalie you get this special
uniform you get all the glory for a
great shot saved but you also get the
grief when you land a shot in the goal
when you're a goalie all eyes are on you
and with that comes the pressure I
distinctly remember one game in high
school I was playing for the California
State team which is part of the Olympic
development program I was having a great
game until I realized that the national
coach was standing right behind me
that's when everything changed in a
matter of seconds
I went from playing at the top to the
bottom of my ability just knowing that I
was being evaluated changed my
performance and forever how I thought
about the mental aspect of how we
perform all of a sudden the ball seemed
to go in slow motion and I was fixated
on my every move the next shot that came
I bobbled but thankfully it didn't land
in the goal this shot after that I
wasn't so lucky I tipped it right into
the net my team lost the national coach
walked away I choked under the pressure
of those evaluative eyes on me just
about everyone does it from time to time
there's so many opportunities whether
it's taking a test giving a talk
pitching to a client or that special
form of torture I like to call the
job interview but the question is why
why do we sometimes fail to perform up
to our potential under pressure
it's especially bewildering in the case
of athletes who spend so much time
physically honing their craft but what
about their minds not as much this is
true off the playing field as well
whether we're taking a test or giving a
talk it's easy to feel like we're ready
at the top of our game and then perform
at our worst when it matters most it
turns out that rarely do we practice
under the types of conditions were
actually going to perform under and as a
result when all eyes are on us we
sometimes flub our performance of course
the question is why is this the case and
my experience on the playing field and
in other important facets of my life
really pushed me into the field of
cognitive science I wanted to know how
we could reach our limitless potential I
wanted to understand how we could use
our knowledge of the mind and the brain
to come up with psychological tools that
would help us perform at our best so why
does it happen why do we sometimes fail
to perform up to what we're capable of
when the pressure is on it may not be so
surprising to hear that in stressful
situations we worry we worry about the
situation the consequences what others
will think of us but what is surprising
is that we often get in our own way
precisely because our worries prompt us
to concentrate too much that's right we
pay too much attention to what we're
doing when we're concerned about
performing our best we often try and
control aspects of what we're doing that
are best left on autopilot outside
conscious awareness and as a result we
mess up think about a situation where
you're shuffling down the stairs and
what would happen
if I asked you to think about what
you're doing with your knee while you're
doing that there's a good chance you'd
fall on your face we as humans only have
the ability to pay attention to so much
at once which is why by the way it's not
a good idea to drive and talk on the
cell phone and under pressure when we're
concerned about performing at our best
we can try and control aspects of what
we're doing that should be left outside
conscious control the end result is that
we mess up my research team and I have
studied this phenomenon of over
attention and we call it paralysis by
analysis in one study we asked college
soccer players to dribble a soccer ball
and to pay attention to an aspect of
their performance that they would not
otherwise attend to we asked them to pay
attention to what side of the foot was
contacting the ball we showed that
performance was slower and more
error-prone when we drew their attention
to the step-by-step details of what they
were doing when the pressure is on were
often concerned with performing at our
best and as a result we try and control
what we're doing to force the best
performance the end result is that we
actually screw up in basketball the term
unconscious is used to describe a
shooter who can't miss and San Antonio
Spurs tart star Tim Duncan has said when
you have to stop and sink that's when
you mess up in dance the great
choreographer George Balanchine used to
urge his dancers don't think just do
when the pressures on when we want to
put our best foot forward somewhat
ironically we often try and control what
we're doing in a way that leads to worse
performance so what do we do knowing
that we have this overactive attention
how do we ensure that we perform at our
best a lot of it comes down to the
prefrontal cortex that front part of our
brain that sits over our eyes and
usually helps us focus in positive ways
it often gets hooked on the wrong things
so how do we unhook it something as
simple as singing a song or paying
attention to one's pinky toe as pro
golfer Jack Nicklaus was rumored to do
can help us take our mind off those
pesky details it's also true that
practicing under conditions that we're
going to perform under closing the gap
between training and competition can
help us get used to that feeling of all
eyes on us this is true off the playing
field as well whether it's getting ready
for an exam or preparing for a big talk
one that might have a little pressure
associated with it getting used to the
types of situations you're going to
perform under really matters when you're
taking a test close the book practice
retrieving the answer from memory under
time situations and when you're giving a
talk practice in front of others and if
you can't find anyone who will listen
practice in front of a video camera or
even a mirror the ability to get used to
what it will feel like can make the
difference in whether we choke or thrive
we've also figured out some ways to get
rid of those pesky worries and self
doubts that tend to creep up in the
stressful situations researchers have
shown that simply jotting down your
thoughts and worries before a stressful
event can help to download them from
mind make them less likely to pop up in
the moment it's kind of like when you
wake up in the middle of the night and
you're really worried about what you
have to do the next day you're trying to
think about everything you have to
accomplish and you write it down and
then you can go back to sleep
journaling or getting those thoughts
down on paper makes it less likely
they'll pop up and distract you in the
moment the end result is that you can
perform your best when it matters most
so up until now I've talked about what
happens when we put limits on ourselves
and some tips we can use to help perform
up to our potential but it's important
to remember that it's not just our own
individual being that can put limits
that can perform poorly our environment
has an effect on whether we choke or
thrive our parents our teachers our
coaches our bosses all influence whether
or not we can put our best foot forward
when it matters most take math as an
example that's right I said it
math lots of people profess to choke or
are anxious about doing math whether
it's taking a test or even calculating
the tip on a dinner bill as our smart
friends work look on and it's quite
socially acceptable to talk about
choking or performing poorly in math you
don't hear highly educated people
walking around talking about the fact or
bragging about the fact that they're not
good readers but you hear people all the
time bragging about how they're not math
people and unfortunately in the u.s.
this tends to be more so among girls and
women than boys and men my research team
and I have tried to understand where
this fear of math comes from and we've
actually peered inside the brains using
functional magnetic resonance imaging of
people who are worried about math we've
shown that math phobia correlates with a
concrete visceral sensation such as pain
of which we have every right to feel
anxious in fact when people who are
worried about math are just getting
ready to take a math test they're not
even taking it they're just getting
ready areas of the brain known to be
involved in our neural pain response are
active when we say math is painful
there's some truth to it for some people
but where does this math anxiety come
from it turns out that math anxiety is
contagious when adults are worried about
math the children around them start
worrying too as young as first grade
when kids are in classrooms with
teachers who are anxious about their own
math ability these kids learn less
across the school year and it turns out
that this is more prevalent in girls
than boys
at this young age kids tend to mimic
same-sex adults and at least in the u.s.
over 90% of our elementary school
teachers are women of course it's not
just what happens in the classroom
social media plays a big role here too
it wasn't so long ago that you could
purchase a teen talk Barbie that when
the cord was pulled it would say things
like will we ever have enough clothes
and math class is tough and just a few
years ago major retailers were marketing
t-shirts at our young girls that read
things like I'm too pretty to do math or
I'm too pretty to do my homework so my
brother does it for me and let's not
forget about the parents oh the parents
it turns out that when parents are
worried about their own math ability and
they help their kids a lot with math
homework their kids learn less math
across the school year as one parent put
it I judge my first graders math
homework by whether it's a one glass
assignment or a three glass night when
adults are anxious about their own math
ability it rubs off on their kids and it
affects whether they choke or thrive but
just as we can put limits on others we
can take them off my research team and I
have shown that when we help parents do
fun math activities with their kids
rather than say just doing bedtime
stories or bedtime reading they do
bedtime math which are fun story
problems to do with your kids at night
not only do children's attitudes about
math improve but their math performance
across the school year improves as well
our environment matters from the
classroom to parents to media and it can
really make a difference in terms of
whether we choke or thrive fast-forward
from my high school soccer game to my
freshman year in college
I was in the chemistry sequence for
science majors and boy did I not belong
even though I studied for my first
midterm exam I thought I was ready to go
I bombed it I literally got the worst
grade in a class of 400 students I was
convinced I wasn't going to be a science
major that maybe I was dropping out of
college altogether but then I changed
how I studied instead of studying alone
I started studying with a group of
friends who at the end of the study
session would close their book and
compete for the right answer we learned
to practice under stress if you could
have looked inside my brain during that
first midterm exam you likely would have
seen a neural pain response a lot like
the math anxious individuals I study it
was probably there during the stressful
study situation as well but when I
walked into the final my mind was quiet
and I actually got one of the highest
grades in the entire class it wasn't
just about learning the material it was
about learning how to overcome my limits
when it mattered most what happens in
our heads really matters and knowing
this we can learn how to prepare
ourselves and others for success not
just on the playing field but in the
boardroom and in the classroom as well
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]